honored is von von Jean watches have 110
World's Fair grand prizes twenty eight
gold medals and more honors for accuracy
than any other timepiece lon Jean the
world's most honored watch is made and
guaranteed by the lawn Jean with no
watch company it's time for the
launching from esco a television journal
of the important issues of the hour
brought show you every Monday Wednesday
and Friday a presentation of the lawn
gene which nor wats company maker of
launching the world's most honored watch
and wit nor distinguished companion to
the world honored lon Jean good evening
this is frank night may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the lawn
Jean chrono scope mr. William white war
correspondent and editor of the Emporia
Gazette and mr. william bradford huie
editor of the american mercury our
distinguished guest for this evening is
dr. HC bird president of Maryland
University the opinions expressed are
necessarily those of the speakers dr.
bird you of course a president of the
University of Maryland the school let's
to play in the Sugar Bowl and our
audience knows something about what
seemed to be a row between you and the
Southern Conference now did you accept
an invitation to play a despite a ruling
from the Southern Conference er we did
not we accepted an invitation within the
rules and regulations Southern
Conference were perfectly valid in what
we did and has the Southern Conference
has taken some action against you as a
result of that that is right Southern
Conference has put us on probation so
far as football is concerned for one
year what kind of a dog house is that
does this doctor how long are they going
to keep
than what they do to well it's a dog
house it's going to earn us about
180,000 dollars for the year time we're
in the dog house so I thought that's
sugar in that sugar bowl just by well
that 180 thousand dollars haven't you
are in that sick well we'll make a
hundred thousand dollars of the sugar
bowl and we'll make a good deal more
money on the football games that will
play with other schools and we would
with the schools that have been
necessarily forced off our schedule by
virtue the action of the conference now
just once again sir how much is the
Sugar Bowl worth to the University of
Maryland how much would you make out of
this about 125 thousand dollars and
you're as a college president you're not
opposed to making that money I said well
I'll tell you I'm Jesuit enough to
believe that it's the purposes to which
money is put rather than the sources
from which it comes you have no
objection to the university of maryland
football team playing before large
crowds and and taking in money well
provided the money is properly used but
the point is you don't object to making
it if it is properly used well I can't
find many people who do objectors if it
is raised in football where we've heard
a lot about over emphasis of football
sir it is football over emphasized at
your school no it is not football is
kept within its proper sphere and does
not interfere in the slightest degree
with any of the academic work and
actually I think it's true in most cases
and most schools it occupies a minor
place actually in university life well
on general sir what is your opinion do
you think you don't think then the
generally foot bone has been emphasized
too much generally no specifically in
some cases yes duck is a much
competition for players down there
there any uh in the Southern Conference
gentleman they go well I think most
white you shouldn't say down there you
should say up here and down there and I
will agree with you sir yes you mean
there's a great deal of competition all
over the cutters correctly and Maryland
is in there pitching I so that is right
and and and you think that's quite
proper for for schools to compete for
the services of college athletes well my
own thinking is that all schools go a
little bit too far in that direction but
but you haven't called totally people at
Maryland to slow down or to compete any
less vigorously had you sir yes we live
we work in that score within wraps as
they may say on the racetrack much more
so than some other institutions do there
are things that we do not do and points
beyond which we do not go now at that
Marilyn you're the president sir now do
you make the policy do you manage sports
at Maryland or do you leave that to your
coaching that's left to an athletic
board which is composed entirely of
members of the faculty and those who are
professionally employed for that purpose
you don't the alumni don't come in for
just a little bit of sale alumni have
anything to do with the management of
athletic oh dear well now what about the
and our audience is her time right after
that too that's that's that's one of the
evils of athletics in some places
there's too much influence cassius
influence on the part of alumni and at
Maryland you feel that you have that
influence under control we not only have
it under control we've eliminated it now
our audience has heard a great deal and
has been perhaps been concerned with the
news about the West Point fix and they
weave around the country we've heard
that that's an indication of the
overemphasis of football now
specifically do you think that the West
Point scandals were the result of over
emphasis of football no I'm inclined to
think and possibly I shouldn't say this
it certainly isn't diplomatic to say
the situation in West Point might have
developed with any group of students
because they just should not have given
the same type of examinations year after
year and asked the same questions year
after year you'd be inclined to excuse
the boys partially and to place the
blame elsewhere for well is okay you
can't excuse dishonesty under any
circumstances but you can develop
circumstances of such a nature as to
prevent opportunities for dishonesty do
you think that there is a general
deterioration among students do you
think that the West Point scandals the
basketball fixes indicate that there is
a deterioration of standards of honor
among students no sir I do not I think
the average college student today is a
better man and the average college girl
today is a better woman than they were
20 years ago and I think they're getting
better and better all the time the
average college student is a pretty
high-class youngster by the way dr. on
this recent ruling of the Federal
Communications Commission and forcing
the free totalizing of games what do you
think about that is the comfort other
conferences right are they FCC what well
my viewpoint about that's a little bit
different from the athletic people they
feel that television is cutting in
greatly on receipts my judgment is that
television cuts in on some particular
games but in the long pole it will do
more in the way of advertising and do
more for athletics or as much for
athletics as any other one factor so
you're not you you are opposed to the
present ruling by the national college
body are you sir I think there should be
no restrictions unless it be you maybe
of a minor nature and
connection with some particular game and
specifically you have no objection to
all of the games played by your school
being televised we would like to have
them televised in first place that makes
that leg board some money and when it
can be used very advantageous you think
that in televising yeah there is more
money to be made in televising than in
restricting televising I do and the long
run yes over the long pole while
specifically for some games and in some
particular season you might lose some
money the resultant advertising in the
building off of interest among people
over the years will be very very
valuable because it's proved in radio
they didn't want radio that the games
broadcast at the start but after a while
they began to see that radio actually
was building better crowd eventually you
think that there will be freedom of
televising you think that all schools
will allow the public will demand it
where's public demands hope it's going
back now sir I'd like to come back just
just one one second to a point that you
made before you believe that it's
perfectly proper for a college president
to plan to make as much money as
possible with his football team well I
doubt if any college president makes
plans of that kind certainly we don't I
don't I do think that it's a good thing
if a football team can make money in a
season because that money helps to carry
on a larger program bringing in more
students helps out the physical
education program and affects a student
body niente do you recognize any ill
effects of the present college football
system thur sawmill effects yet suit to
thee to the men themselves would you say
who are playing you me to the players no
there's no real effects to the players
today do they have
time to carry on that studies in some
schools they may not were a school over
emphasizes the importance of football
that wouldn't have time to do it but
certainly in most institutions type of
institution which I'm thinking state
universities schools like Yale Cornell
they couldn't afford to let football
interfere with their scholastic or
academic work the other way doctor this
matter of academic scholarships one of
the athletic scholarships what are the
rules of the ring on that in the
Southern Conference well frankly they're
a little bit more liberal and they
should be but the Southern Conference
and the southern institutions believe in
absolute open honesty about it and they
do not believe in hiding the hypocrisy
of a situation behind an assumed veil of
ignorance and that's done in some
institutions because they say they have
no athletic scholarships but the app
needs to get scholarships well dr. Byrd
and as I understand your message to our
audience tonight you do not see any
dangers of over emphasis at the moment
you are glad that the University of
Maryland is playing in the Sugar Bowl
and you are very very glad to get the
hundred and twenty-five thousand dollars
from it and you think that the
responsibility is on college presidents
to manage athletics properly thank you
very much for being with us sir the
editorial board for this edition of the
launch in Kronus co was mr. William
white and mr. william bradford huie our
distinguished guest was dr. HC bird
president of Maryland University